gentlemen how are you doing good how you
doing
uh i am doing excellent uh first of all
congrats on this movie uh you guys are
what we call uh talented
actors i'm gonna say i'm gonna say it
like that so uh i like asking a
curveball to start things off for all
three of you if you could get the
financing to make anything that you want
what would you make and why
oof
jesus uh
you know honestly it was this movie to
be honest this was the dream it was the
passion project and we did it at a at
the budget that we could do it and not
have to compromise and make the movie
that we wanted to so i you know i can't
think off the top of my head something
else like that you know
maybe someday no yeah you know i feel
like we did it i think i think
people
they say well did you have a good time
and i i think that people this was
difficult this was truly a difficult
piece
and i always tell people with a lot of
the things that i play just speaking for
myself never mistake difficulty with not
having a good time
this was tough
but when you come out of this
it's so much more rewarding i've had a
good time on pieces
that i can't stand to watch
you know what i mean this was
brutal in its
in its making on a day-to-day basis but
we had an incredible incredible time on
this piece i wouldn't trade
yeah if i had you know you give me the
money this is it right here
anything you want to add john i'm i'm
with them you know look i i look man
it's you know people throw that term out
you know passion projects and you know
john and i met over 10 years ago you
know at a play reading of this play you
know we we uh
yeah you know i i
we did this play in a 40 seat theater at
10 30 at night every night and and it
was uh you know at that point was the
singular most satisfying artistic
experience of my life um and and it
brought me one of my best friends and
and my primary sort of artistic you know
partner and collaborator and the guy i
bounce everything off of and and um you
know we've been talking about this
forever and um you know we finally did
it and then to bring in shae it's just
you know it's one sort of glorious thing
after another and uh you know so look
you know i think we're all really proud
of the film i think i think the
challenges of of what made this a really
really special and dangerous and
thought-provoking and and complicated
play i think we're able to achieve uh
the same if not more as the film so uh
yeah i i i think doing stuff you believe
in with people that you believe in as
well that's that's that's that's the
idea
uh i'm gonna use john p to so i don't
have to keep on you know
so i'm i'm from new england and i saw a
lot of stuff in this movie that i'm very
familiar with whether it be the people
on display the the uh just there's so
much that i saw but my big objection to
the film is how could you not have
someone drinking dunkin donuts
uh you know man uh
i'm joking by the way i'm joking about
it i i hear you you know i've i've
written other plays uh one of the
opening lines in in the sort of play i
wrote after smalling repair called lost
girls which is sort of the female
thematic companion piece to the play
they mentioned donkeys left and right
the way my family does at home uh you
know i just felt like with the movie i
really wanted to avoid as many of those
sort of cliches and then there's
licensing issues obviously i mean you
know we couldn't get licensing to have
every the reality is you go to new
england everybody's wearing some sort of
red socks celtics you know thing it's
like the clothing brand we just you know
a small film like that you just don't
have licensing so uh i just never went
that way
i apologize i want to make sure i say
her name right uh is it ciara
yeah okay so um when when i heard
ciara's accent i was like oh wow this is
the real deal when she delivered that
accent on set were all three of you like
[ __ ] i'm gonna have to step up my game
yeah
we kind of he came into our our universe
uh you know we knew she was something
i mean she's just an enormously special
talented and strong
you know artist and and she came in and
she had this ability to be both so
powerful and so fragile at the same time
and and you totally believe that she was
raised by the she had like an element of
each of these men and she she also you
could see that she sort of surpassed
each of them as well in her own kind of
uh evolution um she's someone that um
you you absolutely believe that all
three of these guys just revere and and
would do anything to protect and um hold
on this pedestal and uh she's incredible
she's really incredible
oh yeah a 100 for all three of you guys
um i love learning about like the behind
the scenes of the making of a movie
things that you might not know um can
you share maybe things that might
surprise people to learn about the
making of this film
um they might be surprised at how
goddamn cold it was through like half of
the scenes that you know you're just out
there shooting again and again and it
was like two degrees out on some of
those things uh and what i didn't
realize was how that how when it's that
cold how it affects the sort of texture
of the of the of the image which was
great it has that
you know new england cold
you know harsh quality that really
translated really well uh we didn't
necessarily plan that but that was all
uh that all was captured i think
there's there's ton of heart in this
piece man uh you know in its history and
in in the way we shot it you know um you
know we when we did this as a play my
dog boss i think you've met he was uh
you know he was he was backstage at
every single rehearsal every single
performance he also was the old dog uh
you know in in he was frank's dog in the
in the movie and then my youngest dog
bam bam was was that dog in flashbacks
you know all of our kids you know
participated in this movie everybody who
has uh played the role these roles in
other productions they came in to do
smaller parts um it was a real labor of
love you know
a ton of heart the kind of heart that's
that that's kind of undeniable and i
think it comes through
that's a way better answer go with that
one though yeah
that's the answer
it was cold though it was cool it was
cold i don't know man you know
uh do you want to add anything no no i
agree you know agree with both of those
this is one of those films where it's
kind of hard to talk about everything
because there's a lot that happens and
i'm sort of curious when you've been
telling like friends who may not might
not know the play or might not know the
movie how have you been describing the
film to people if you don't mind
i you know we've said we've said before
you know the film doesn't fall into any
one genre and i think that's what makes
it so unique and special you know it's
it's it's as funny you know it's this
funny buddy comedy but then it gets
really really dangerous and then um
there's all these kinds of twists and
turns and in in one second you're in
this kind of movie the other second
you're in this but what's uniform all
the way through
is the reality and the the the the
palpability and the believability of the
relationships because it's so funny and
the humor is so focused on these guys
really having a history with each other
you know when we did the play
you you it was so dangerous in that room
it was so electric you never knew what
was gonna happen next and that's really
what we went for in the movie you know
like a tarantino movie all of a sudden
you you you're in something totally
different but but but you believe that
that that you're there i think that this
is the kind of movie
that um you're gonna you're gonna laugh
your ass off and and there's probably a
really good shot that you're gonna cry
and there's definitely a shot that
you're gonna be provoked you might even
be offended and i think we welcome all
of that and uh i think it's it's just
not that this is not this is not the
kind of film that you're going to go to
and say
uh you know
it just it will affect you and knowing
that that's that's the kind of art that
we want to make you know and and and i
think we're really proud of that
i agree with everything you just said um
uh john p i'm curious if you could talk
a little bit i love talking about
editing because that's the final rewrite
it's where it all comes together can you
sort of talk about what you learned in
the editing room that maybe you weren't
expecting and any sort of tweaks that
happened to make sure that the audience
wasn't sort of ahead of where the story
was going
you know that's a great question the
edit was an incredible
experience and
and we had two different editors on and
we we went through a whole process with
that i mean we you know moving at this
budget you can't do multiple
test screenings so some of that stuff
was uh you kind of had to go with your
gut but the movie
lays out certain plot elements more so
than the play so the play is like your
captive audience and people lean in and
they listen and in a film you know we
had to
visually telegraph it the bread there's
a lot more breadcrumbs in the movie um
and you know you you shoot a number of
things what i was most impressed about
with the editing was
how look on the
i asked a lot of directors before and i
was like how do you know when you've
done when you're done with the take and
you move on and they're like you kind of
just go with your gut
but they're like nine times out of ten
the take you think is the take you're
going to use
doesn't end up being the one and what i
was so
enjoyed about the editing process was
like these sort of gifts that when you
work with actors like this these gifts
they give and different versions like
seeing shay on the day it felt really
good we moved on but then you're in the
edit you're like oh my god he gave us
all these different
avenues and the same with john his
performance was so great you never had
to cut around a performance you always
had options in in the way they were
listening and pivoting on each other so
really it took on a life of its own
because because to your point steven is
like there's the you know there's the
movie you write the movie you shoot and
then the movie you edit and it
definitely evolved and what happened was
is the performances in the characters
took over the edit of the movie and
informed the truth of every of the story
in ways that
the script was uh
you know the the performances were so
effective in in many ways you didn't
need a lot of the stuff that was in the
script
i completely get it listen all three of
you guys congrats on the movie you did
such a great job um and thank you for
talking with me and have a great day
nice to see you